und jetzt das heute journal guten abend
der ball in münchen rollt und der
regenbogen ist sichtbar auch ohne
stadion beleuchtung oder gerade deshalb
das lieferverbot hat den protest gegen
die ungarische regierung und die ihr
umstrittenes gesetz zur homosexualität
heute befeuert auch politisch
bundeskanzlerin merkel nannte das gesetz
falsch von einer schande sprach eu
kommissionspräsident in von der leyen
und deutschland macht sich bunt patricia
schäfer der regenbogen ist zwar nicht
auf dem münchner em stadion zu sehen
dafür allgegenwärtig davor die fähnchen
finden reißenden absatz ein bunter
protest gegen die uefa entscheidung
die politischen themen von den
sportlichen themen trennen aber jetzt
natürlich erfahren dass hier vertrauen
der regenbogen verbot der uefa macht die
fans meinungsfreudig und kreativ eine
initiative hat passende masken gedruckt
und verteilt sie vor dem stadion
es besteht zwar aus richtung etwas
bezahlen lassen können sie gar nicht
verbieten dass die haben fleißig verkehr
der protest richtet sich gegen ein
gesetz das letzte woche in ungarn
verabschiedet wurde
er sieht unter anderem vor dass in
büchern und filmen die kindern
zugänglich sind nur noch heterosexuelle
liebespaare zu sehen sein dürfen
in ihrer letzten fragestunde
kommentierte das heute auch die
bundeskanzlerin erstmal halte ich dieses
gesetz für falsch und auch mit meiner
vorstellung von politik nicht vereinbar
wenn man homosexuelle
gleichgeschlechtliche
lebenspartnerschaften erlaubt aber die
aufklärung darüber an anderer stelle
einschränkt die eu kommission hat heute
angekündigt gegen das umstrittene gesetz
vorzugehen
dieses gesetz diskriminiert menschen
aufgrund ihrer sexuellen orientierung
und geht gegen alle werte die
fundamentalen werte der europäischen
union
da lassen wir nicht mit uns verhandeln
und dann leuchtet an der allianz arena
doch noch ein regenbogen am windrad
neben dem stadion nachfrage bei unseren
korrespondenten in budapest und münchen
stefan leifert der antrag des münchner
ob er das ganze jahr ins rollen gebracht
er hat im grunde ja jetzt mehr erreicht
versatz gedacht
ja das kann man so sagen und die
münchner sind auch ein bisschen stolz
darauf denn die regenbogen welle
weltweit die von münchen ihren ausgang
nahmen die hat jetzt eine viel größere
wirkung entfaltet als sie je hätte
entfalten können wenn die uefa dem
wunsch der stadt münchen entsprochen
hätte und hier das stadion einfach im
regenbogen flaggen erleuchtet hätte
nicht trotz sondern wegen des verbots
leuchtete münchen heute umso heller in
den farben des regenbogens und weltweit
haben sich menschen im netz
solidarisiert mit der lgbt szene in
ungarn die uefa hat sich damit
ihrerseits ein doppeltes eigentor
eingehandelt kann man sagen auf der
einen seite deswegen weil sie jetzt
ziemlich einsam an der seite von viktor
orban steht und weltweit hagelt es
protest und zweitens hat sie sich
deswegen auch ein eigentor geschossen
weil sie ihr eigenes argument entkräftet
hat dass der fußball doch eigentlich was
unpolitisch sein politisches sei mit
dieser mehr haben münchen und die uefa
ob sie es wollten oder nicht gründlich
aufgeräumt
britta hilpert auf dem heldenplatz in
budapest viktor orban hat ja sein besuch
beim spiel in münchen abgesagt zeigt der
protest also wirkung wirkung ja aber
nicht in richtung einlenken die kritik
der eu-kommission beruhe auf unwahren
behauptung sie sei eine schande
der präsident der republik ungarn hat
heute abend das umstrittene gesetz
unterschrieben
kein einlenken also aber vielleicht ist
das auch genau das kalkül denn viktor
orban hat im nächsten jahr wahrheit zu
bestreiten und seine erfahrung ist dass
er immer dann im inneren stärker wird
wenn er von außen angefeindet wird
und genau so stellt es die größtenteils
regierungsfreundliche presse in ungarn
da die eu-kritik seien nichts anderes
als ein angriff auf die nationale
selbstbestimmung dankeschön nach
budapest und münchen und in den
nachrichten gehen wir jetzt nach berlin
konnte lag auf einer internationalen
konferenz wurde dort über frieden und
stabilität für libyen beraten
nach zehn jahren bürgerkrieg ist die
waffenruhe in dem nordafrikanischen land
noch zerbrechlich us-außenminister
blinken und vertreter der
konfliktparteien briten über
diplomatische lösungen aus minister
es drängte erneut auf den abzug aller
ausländischen truppen und freie wahlen
im dezember
russland hat im schwarzen meer vor der
russisch besetzten halbinsel krim nach
eigenen angaben warnschüsse nahe eines
britischen kriegsschiff abgefeuert
moskau sieht eine verletzung russische
hoheitsgewässer und eine grobe
provokation dagegen heißt es aus london
der zerstörer sms defender sei auf einer
harmlosen durchfahrt durch zitaten
klinische gewässer gewesen
im einklang mit internationalem recht
auch in deutschland breitet sich die
delta variante des corona virus weiter
aus politik und ärzte warnen vor
nachlässigkeit und drängen auf mehr
impfungen
der anteil aller neuinfektionen durch
die delta variante ist hierzulande auf
über 15 prozent gestiegen die inzidenz
sinkt dagegen weiter auf jetzt 7,2 der
bund will auch im nächsten jahr massiv
schulden aufnehmen der haushaltsentwurf
von finanzminister scholz sieht wegen
corona klimaschutz und geringerer
steuereinnahmen eine neuverschuldung von
fast 100 milliarden euro vor
über den haushalt entschieden wird aber
erst nach der bundestagswahl am 26
september
außerdem hat das bundeskabinett ein
sofortprogramm für den klimaschutz
beschlossen acht milliarden euro sollen
investiert werden um das neue
klimaschutzgesetz umzusetzen
morgen befasst sich der bundestag damit
der co2 ausstoß soll demnach bis 2030 um
65 prozent im vergleich zu 1990 sinken
bis 2040 um 88 prozent
das ziel der klimaneutralität soll bis
2045 erreicht sein
im deutschen bundestag lag heute
abschied in der luft für viele
abgeordnete ist es die letzte
parlamentswoche und auch die
bundeskanzlerin hatte einen der
abschieds termine die sie jetzt nach und
nach absolviert zum letzten mal konnten
die abgeordneten sie in einer
regierungsbefragung in die zange nehmen
obwohl gefährlich wurde ihr nicht
wirklich jemand dafür gab es momente um
bilanz zu ziehen
heike slansky kaum etwas bringt sie aus
der ruhe keine fragestunde keine
abgeordneten keine wahlkampfmanöver
stimmt das mit ihrem wissen über ein den
koalitionspartner charmant abgewatscht
es ist ihre zehnte fragestunde
routiniert konnte hat sie alle angriffe
macht aus ihrer abneigung zu afd kein
hier was diese aussage mit dem beziehung
zu den golfstaaten zu tun hat hat sie
mich sich mir nicht verschlossen und das
glaube ich ja mal launig meist sachlich
immer konzentriert ob zur rente eine
verlängerung der lebensarbeitszeit steht
für mich nicht auf der tagesordnung zur
angeblichen einsatzfähigkeit der
bundeswehr
ich teile die einschätzung erst einmal
in der pauschalität nicht oder zur
digitalisierung man glaubt es nicht aber
als ich bundeskanzlerin wurde gab es das
iphone noch nicht eine ära geht zu ende
merkel r liegt keiner versuchung auch
nicht auf die frage ob nicht eine frau
ihre nachfolgerin werden sollte
ich bin der meinung dass nach 16 jahre
angela merkel die bürgerinnen und bürger
mündig genug sind ihre entscheidung zu
treffen wen sie als kanzler möchten oder
als kanzlerin die letzte fragestunde der
kanzlerin corona klima oder wohnpolitik
fragen gäbe es nach 16 jahren reichlich
aber ich darf die befragung nicht
verlängern
keine spur von abschiedsschmerz keine
sentimentalitäten ihr schlusswort ich
bedanke mich dass sie ihren regeln
entsprechend handeln
sprach's und eilte zum nächsten termin
und wir haben noch services wetter und
die gewinnzahlen vom lotto am mittwoch
sie lauten 5 69 20 33 46 superzahl 5
mehr auf lotto zdf de und im zdf text es
gibt eine unwetterwarnung des deutschen
wetterdienstes vor zum teil extremen
gewittern heftigem starkregen und hagel
in teilen von bayern
und das wetter bleibt vorerst
unbeständig
meist freundlich ist es morgen nur im
norden in der mitte und im süden
entwickeln sich schauer und gewitter
teils unwetter mit starkregen hagel und
sturmböen
bei 18 bis 27 grad am freitag 19 bis 23
grad und im süden kräftige schauer und
gewitter
am wochenende wird es wärmer schauer und
gewitter werden dann seltener mit
unwettern ist nicht mehr zu rechnen
sodann weiter direkt mit der zweiten
halbzeit zurück ins sportstudio ist und
einen guten abend
[Musik]